[Music]
we all hear about big demographic
changes underway these days in China the
world's most populous country following
birth rates rapid population aging and
shrinking workforce totals with national
population decline just around the
corner yet the most important population
change in China today maybe when we
seldom hear about one that Chinese
population controllers almost never
mentioned this is the revolution in
Chinese family structure an astonishing
transformation a major break with old
past patterns an unstoppable trend
driving China into completely new
uncharted social territory the vanguard
of this revolution is China's new family
type
only children begotten by only children
this rising group of young men and women
has no siblings cousins uncle's or aunts
only ancestors maybe someday descendants
extended family networks have been the
foundation of social and economic life
in China since Chinese civilization
began but now these networks are
atrophying and for millions evaporating
all together while trying to manage to
cope or is just a huge civilization
challenging surprise
stay tuned what do you think is China's
most pressing population problem let us
know in our poll also let us know what
other topics you'd like our scholars to
cover in 60 seconds be sure to LIKE and
subscribe for more research and videos
from AEI